- Tell me about Philly.
Were you a cheesesteak guy growing up?
- Oh, I'm a cheesesteak guy.
- Oh, okay.
- Still. Yeah, still.
Well, not right now on the Whole30,
but you know-
- Okay.
- In Philly, anybody who goes to Philly,
you have to figure out
which cheesesteak you love.
- Right.
- Do you like Gino's? Do you like Pat's?
- Gino's and Pat's
You know, I-
- Have you experienced them?
- I'm an independent.
- Yeah.
- I can go either way-
- Either way.
- Depending on the particular steak.
- But I have to ask you,
do you like Cheez Whiz on yours?
- I opt for the Provolone.
But that's-
- Oh, look at!
See, this is a man who
really knows cheesesteaks.
- See that is my Italian heritage.
Cheez Whiz, just the
name Whiz turns me off.
(Colman laughing)
I don't want any Whiz on my,
you know, when people say-
- You don't have
any Whiz on your cheesesteak.
- Yeah, what do you want?
First time I had one, "Hey,
you want some Whiz on that?"
No!
(Colman laughing)
No, I don't want Whiz on it!
- You're like,
dude, it's just craft.
- Yeah, yeah.
- It's just craft.
- I know, but Whiz-
- Fried onions?
- And it even comes out of a can.
Cheese in a can, yeah, no.
So to me, the Provolone,
the guy cuts and puts
a nice piece on there.
- But do you like it
to look neat or sloppy?
Because Philly, it's gotta be a mess
and it's just like, it's
gonna get all over you.
- Yeah, either way is fine.
- Okay, cool.
- I can, you know, I can-
- I'm not judging.
- I'm not Orthodox, I'm
reformed cheesesteak.
(Colman laughing)
So I could go sloppy, yeah, yeah.
Orthodox would be the, yeah,
but the reformed cheesesteak, yeah, yeah.
(Colman laughing)
It is very good.